[Música]
y llegó el momento de hablar de economía
en France 24 por ello les voy a dar la
bienvenida a mi compañero Juan Pablo qué
tal Buenas noches todo muy bien Andrés
Juan Pablo vamos a empezar en Colombia
porque se aprobó una ley para que los
usuarios se protejan del fraude digital
de qué se trata pues Andrés me imagino
que usted conoce casos de suplantación
de fraude de todos estos escenarios y
pues es muy común en este país en
Colombia estos escenarios de estafas en
línea Pues precisamente lo que busca
esta ley de la que hablaremos más a
continuación es que si en estos casos de
su planteación se activaron créditos o
se hicieron compras que comprometan a la
persona a seguir pagando esta
responsabilidades pues el usuario pueda
aprobar ante las entidades financieras
que se trata de una farsa y que quede
libre de seguir pagando a la entidad
nosotros pudimos hablar con el
congresista que lideró este proyecto
duvalier Sánchez y esto fue lo que nos
dijo Gracias Juan Pablo rápidamente te
cuento que esta ley es Útil para al
menos 40.000 colombianos que según lazo
bancario todos los años son víctimas de
créditos financieros que sacan a través
de la suplantación de su identidad y
terminen en una angustia por pagar una
deuda que no eligieron y si es estafa no
se paga si es suplantación no se debe
pagar Qué hace la ley Pues el ciudadano
Tan pronto se da cuenta llama Reporta la
entidad financiera que fue víctima de
una suplantación de su identidad y se
debe suspender cualquier cobro de la
deuda o de los intereses el otro
beneficio que se hace Es que si llegó a
ser reportado en las centrales de
riesgos por esta causa debe salir de esa
de esa condición es una ley que están
esperando miles de amigos familiares de
ciudadanos que son víctimas y que cuando
sean estas situaciones hoy la compañía
se desentiende y le obliga a cobrar
hasta que la situación se resuelva en
una entidad ante la justicia o ante la
fiscalía Así que a partir de ahora el
ciudadano es víctima y es la compañía la
responsable de aclarar la situación con
la evidencia que tenga o con el proceso
administrativo que se adelante buena
iniciativa para los ciudadanos de a pie
Juan Pablo seguimos ahora en América
Latina pero más al sur porque hoy se
conoció el dato de inflación de chile se
trata del dato más reciente es decir el
de mayo la tasa sigue su camino a la
baja en ese país y se ubicó en el 8,7%
anual en el quinto mes de este año según
los datos del Instituto Nacional de
estadística de ese país lo que supone su
nivel más bajo desde febrero de 2022 y
también es el sexto mes consecutivo que
se registra un descenso desde el 13,3%
interanual que alcanzó en noviembre hoy
también se conocieron los datos de
inflación de Colombia y de Brasil y pues
también fueron meses en donde hubo
descensos en estos países es decir ya
tenemos datos de las principales
economías de América Latina y van bien Y
seguramente estos datos movieron las
bolsas en la región Así es Empezando por
Estados Unidos que cerró en positivo
esto en un escenario con sus tres
principales indicadores al alza también
para América Latina Tuvo una ganancia en
el caso de México con un 0,09% Argentina
también una ganancia y en el caso del
indicador de Brasil no operó por ser día
festivo si pasamos entonces para hablar
de Asia en este panorama el escenario
fue mixto con Tokio y Hong Kong con
ganancias y en el caso de Sydney que
tuvo una leve pérdida bien Ahora
hablamos de la reunión entre el
presidente Joe biden y el Primer
Ministro Richie sunat de Qué temas
económicos hablaron ambos líderes pues
llegaron a un acuerdo de que le llamaron
como la declaración del Atlántico que se
enfocará en aumentar la cooperación
bilateral de transición energética
reforzar las cadenas de suministro y no
perder de vista el área de tecnología
con el avance de la Inteligencia
artificial en el pasado se ha hablado de
un posible tratado de libre comercio
entre ambos países en esta ocasión se
les preguntó por qué todavía esto no se
ha consumado Su respuesta fue que con la
declaración atlántica se empieza a limar
algunas de las diferencias que ocasionó
la ley de reducción de inflación que
vaiden pues en su momento hizo también
enojar a varios países europeos por el
fortalecimiento de las empresas
estadounidenses y la subvención de las
europeas dentro de sus planes está la
fabricación de paneles solares batería
de vehículos eléctricos misiles
hipersónicos y la preservación de
algunos minerales indispensables para la
transición energética esto dijo el
presidente de Estados Unidos
podemos discutir para hacer planes para
fortalecer aún más nuestra relación
económica la economía global está
experimentando creo la mayor
transformación que ha ocurrido desde la
Revolución Industrial eso es algo de lo
que sabes mucho y la Inteligencia
artificial va a jugar un papel
importante
Y es que precisamente sobre la
Inteligencia artificial enfocaron su
discurso ambos líderes el Primer
Ministro británico por ejemplo dijo que
Reino Unido será sede de la primera
Cumbre internacional sobre este tema
para el próximo otoño escuchemos
nuestras economías están experimentando
quizás la mayor transformación desde la
Revolución Industrial ya que las nuevas
tecnologías brindan oportunidades
increíbles pero también brindan a
nuestros adversarios más herramientas
para hacer daño pero una cosa que sé que
no cambiará es la fuerza de nuestra
asociación nuestra amistad la
Inteligencia artificial siempre cada día
más integrada en nuestra cotidianidad
Juan Pablo Cuál es la cifra del día y
acá también lo veremos porque es uno
coma seis millones de dólares que costó
hacer este ferry autónomo y eléctrico en
estocolmo este transporte autónomo
convierte a la capital de Suecia en la
pues primera ciudad del mundo en Poner
este tipo de servicio no sé si usted se
montaría en uno de estos vehículos
operados por la inteligencia no recuerdo
haberme montado nunca en un ferry no sé
si lo harían este Ah bueno ya veremos
Juan Pablo Muchas gracias por la
información económica nos vemos mañana
entonces con la actualización con mucho
más Andrés seguimos